fans of the show know we love bud light
seltzer and you know what we love more
than bud light seltzer when they sponsor
the show they are the presenting sponsor
you know about bud light seltzer it's a
delicious hard seltzer from bud light
with no bud light in it each one is only
100 calories 5 alcohol by volume and
gluten free and now they get the perfect
flavors for summer with the bud light
seltzer lemonade variety pack and the
brand new bud light seltzer ice tea
variety pack you can try them together
which christian did the other day and
make your ideal alcoholic arnold palmer
with a bud light seltzer iced tea and
lemonade mix pack or dive into the good
vibes of yesteryear with the retro
summer pack and retro summer icicles
there's that cherry limeade that's my
fine flavors and you know when you can
combine there's a peach iced tea and
lemonade you combine those together get
a peach arnold palmer stay tuned to hear
more about bud light seltzer's newest
offerings and a little more about us and
our summer memories later in the show
but now the show
[Music]
my first summer job my first real summer
job was working as first a bag boy
that's not pejorative i was a boy and i
bagged groceries i hate day country farm
market which shout out shout out well
now i don't think you can give a shout
out to something that doesn't exist
anymore it used to be on the post road
in westport shout out that still exists
and um
and it was sort of like a precursor to
whole foods it was like a very fancy
supermarket and so i started as a bag
boy and then i moved to um produce guys
so i was i knew i got to learn whatever
that's not important what's the story
here's the story a lady there's one
homeless person who would come in and
help themselves to free samples and
i used to offer them other things and
stuff and nothing that would have cost
money but they were free to other people
and the manager of the store once kicked
her out
and i was so livid that i took off my
apron and i quit and i stormed out
and uh i ended up
going back and writing a letter and
saying sorry and i really regret that
sorry to your boss yeah yeah so that's
when you realized that you cared more
about petty cash than helping a homeless
person i mean it was a real turning
point i mean it was a it was a moment
where i could have become like a real
activist and somebody with convictions
and i and i chose the other path well i
think you've made up for it throughout
the course of your life thank you i i do
try because it is something that
affected me and uh and hopefully this
show is something that affects you guys
in a positive way yes yes queen queens
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening in fact to life is
short i'm your host justin long who has
some regrets life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is
my brother christian who's looking at a
uh i just realized we were just talking
about phoebe birds uh-huh and i'm using
a coaster i was wondering why you were
staring at that coaster that um has a
phoebe bird on it i think that's isn't
that a phoebe um let's see it's a blue
bird oh maybe it looks like it is the
face of a phoebe wow you're getting to
know birds well you know i would never
have guessed that before you had uh we
were just talking about
we were just lost we were just talking
about it phoebe birds are great because
they eat flies and things like that in
your yard so they're good for humans oh
yeah a lot of birds it's good to set up
bird feeders that have small enough food
holes so that only they can get food
holes so only they can get the food and
they remain plentiful in your yard
that's interesting i was just watching a
program a nature program on the
galapagos islands
yes sorry good morning
9 15 i said before
wow you're ambitious
i went to sleep late who cares i was
watching also who cares i was watching a
galapagos show um and god was it uh this
the birds the stuff of the hawk oh the
hawk eating the horror the galapagos
hawk but then the the albatross stuff
and how they mate for life and how
beautiful that is but i mean it ranges
from like which i think of nature it
ranges from the most savage
to just the
stunningly beautiful and
not to take your positive story about
the phoebes and the flies but the sav on
the savage end of the bird scale um is
what happens to the blue footed booby
babies which i know sounds funny you're
saying savage like logan paul says it
yeah exactly
tick tocker
yeah it's savage um anyway they
basically kick one of them why am i
saying this on a fun
show they kick one of the babies out of
the nest and it has to die i mean
they just choose one of the two they lay
two eggs
you know i think you're telling it
because our guest today is so
entertaining and enjoyable that you need
to balance out the show yes some tragedy
yes i think maybe so
but he's also our guest today is also uh
interesting i mean i think a lot of his
comedy comes from pathos
um he is uh he does these really big
characters sometimes broad in um on
occasion but he does them in very
grounded way he's able to he's one of
those rare entertainers who can do a
bigger character but keep it grounded
yes and also specifically to connect him
to
the story you told about
uh
your sorry day
experience in the hate my heyday my
haitian your heyday yeah that was my
heyday i don't know if it was my heyday
no i would say it was before your head
yes it was you worked at hay day before
your heyday that's true a few years
before uh in fact i when i was 15 i
don't think i'd yet gone through puberty
i was like a little so when i took that
it must have been looked funny when i
took that defiant stance when i was like
well then i quit and i stormed out must
have been
i think i wrote her a letter to be like
look here's why i did it and uh because
i wanted her to know that sure she can't
treat people like that but i to me it
was such a gross
exam there was so that place made so
much money there were so many wealthy
people there she just didn't want
somebody who was like mmm like of a
lesser class at the clientele yes um
but so she was your boss yep and someone
else played your boss ah in a
i would say
classic movie at this point oh you
hesitated but i know why you guys it's
not yeah well the guest today we should
get to yes who played your boss i'm
going on a lot of tangents
well it's early yeah your alarm just
went off okay yes our guest today
is the very funny actor that great actor
and my friend david kechner who played
your boss
in
waiting oh wow yeah that was circuitous
i don't know if it was the classic i did
hesitate because i think
some people listening will think oh yeah
it's definitely a classic and some
people will think i haven't seen that
well it depends on your definition of
classic i mean i would say dodgeball is
more of a classic
yes because i think dodgers and galaxy
quest i think they're better movies
um by the way this takes nothing away
from my experience of doing that movie i
it was one of that might have been a
heyday i think that was your payday yes
but the movie it wasn't ryan reynolds
heyday he had his heyday later he's in
his heyday
he is
uh that but that movie i think is it's
good and funny but people hold it so
dear people who work i know oh my god in
the restaurant industry oh are like all
the time so many people come up to you
over the years be like
that all the time means so much to me
because i worked in that industry and
like i could relate so much oh my god so
i think four people in that industry it
is definitely a classic oh he's been in
he is he's been in everything he is
hilarious
in anchorman and anchorman ii
i think one of the best
big comedies
in my life anchorman yeah it's very hard
to beat them and there's some really
funny stuff in increment too i'm
thinking of when he goes back uh he
plays champ a champ kind of sports okay
that's right and he's got a uh it's
he's got a phrase his phrase is whammy
um
so hard well he's also such a great
singer what he's like what he does with
his voice is incredible um but he's
it's like a real instrument to him and
we both do a show together called f is
for family uh he's plays a very funny
character in that we talk about that we
talk about waiting we talk about really
everything everything catch-up because
you haven't seen each other right we
keck up you
uh so here's my keck up with the very
funny
kind
my friend my old friend my kind kind
thank you dave kechner
life could be a dream
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
all right
[Laughter]
what i love that background it's it's
very hollywood i know right i started a
company
oh that does zoom entertainment
for business meetings there's such zoom
fatigue
yeah
that um i thought there's a market for
this because if you think about every
meeting's a [ __ ] zoom meeting so i
created this platform well it's not
platform yet but it's a business where
i'll jump in to their meeting for 10 20
or or half an hour for different prices
the lowest level is just i jump into the
meeting and pop in and say hi and talk
to them for 10 minutes and they're out
10 minutes go so [ __ ] fast
then for the next level is we'll have
it's already been 12.
the next level is you can meet with our
writers
and fill out a questionnaire and we can
tailor some comedy to your 15 minute
event and then the next level is 20 or
half an hour but what we do are we do an
opening monologue we'll do what we call
a fake commercial for that company we'll
do um champ kind does the news of your
company
another fun one we found which is called
background check
which is basically uh there'll be 50
people in the zoom we'll have our our
tech person just spotlight myself and
another person then i'll comment on
their background we'll do like five or
six of them like if i was doing with you
right now yeah like oh you're an
aspiring sound man but not really uh
you're not really any musician but you
want people to know you have a guitar
you're using it more of a
as a cork board than as a sound bounce
oh look how green you are oh i've i use
recycled paper for my kleenex and i've
got crayons i like to draw this this
lamp is something my mom gave me then
then they would literally be that long
for you and then we jump to the next one
and then we do this other thing called
whatever your name is hi
the soap opera a cw show and we've had
that template already written they just
basically zoom in on our person then we
do so great
todd packer interviews for your company
what's that what todd packer from the
from the office yeah yeah the worst
person in the world so we give them the
that's all written we give them the
sweat so they have one person on their
at their company their hr person usually
i interview todd packer
and then we have all these questions and
then packer gives his packer answer and
then usually what do we do after that oh
then we usually just do a quick short
song out and that's it that's the half
hour show so it's you and who else dave
right now it's just me just like in life
we all want to be seen and heard yeah
yeah and that's not really making fun
that's not being cruel to a person
noticing what we all do yeah it's it's
although i mean
having said that it must be difficult
to do you ever find yourself having to
tiptoe or having a hard time if there's
something you want to let's say
something jumps to your mind because
you're so quick and that's what you do
that's what this whole thing is is just
pointing things out god forbid something
jumps to your mind that is offensive or
well
people don't want to be ashamed people
like yourself or myself because we do
comedy nothing comes singularly
so there's three things that'll always
come and del close or my old teacher
would say think three things and then
choose the best one because you're
always going to think three yeah
probably
and then you can you can if you can't
edit we wouldn't be where we are so
that's true that's true yeah and you're
very smart a smart person so
yeah and you and i don't imagine that
you have you're i don't
i would guess that your brain doesn't
really work like that where it's it's
mean it finds the mean things you're
very compassionate i couldn't i couldn't
do a roast battle i mean i cried i could
you could but then it'd be like
do you take out their knees because it's
forever
that's not my thing so tell me i'm like
whatever i i've done a couple corporate
roasts
um
and those are not i won't do those again
what what are those like
because you really don't know the people
really rich people uh-huh and they
always um
misjudge
what the event should be
i i did one that was a vendetta and i
didn't know it
oh my god until i got there is in san
francisco for a bunch of super wealthy
people i'm talking about the poorest
person that they'd make fun of the one
guy who only has 50 million dollars oh
gross gross oh and he was the guy being
roasted and apparently he'd already he
had by the time
i got the gig
and then worked with writers and then
when did the gig
he'd hit on something else so he added
another 40 million dollars to his value
so anyway the woman had organized his
birthday party it wasn't his birthday oh
uh he had said something shitty at her
birthday six months earlier so the whole
thing oh she was getting him back it was
a pure vendetta yes that's all it was so
there was no love in it whatsoever at
what point i'm curious when you got to
this event at what point did you find
out it was this if it was a pure
vendetta oh right away i said i'd like
to meet the guy yeah or the event just
to get something to say about him yeah
yeah no i already have the material oh
okay all the material was about a fat
guy he had lost 75 pounds
[Laughter]
it was just [ __ ] stupid uh-huh like
oh okay
okay and also gross that like that's the
value system they probably wanted you to
say
uh this stuff about how little money he
has and oh god yeah he's only got 50
million and he's fat and he's like well
none of those things are true he wants
you know to me i was like this guy is
just turning into my favorite guy at the
uh right this is the one you respected
the most
yeah
wait what um in terms of this venture
because i'm also curious about this that
the zoom
what do you call it by the way dave uh
hey good meeting
oh that's good all right hey this is a
good meeting hey good meeting let's have
a good meeting not a bad meeting well
good meeting there
so you've touched on uh some characters
that i want to talk about well first of
all the vendetta the um
the thing that you had to do about the
uh the poor rich guy
um
was the i'm i'm picturing a bunch of
bill braskey's it's one of my favorite
sketches on snl and i i i'm now i'm just
picturing those guys
yeah in a way but just not equipped for
humor
um
and it's all about it the thing that
struck me is like clearly this is first
generation money uh-huh that's that's
the other interesting part yeah because
the only thing they talked about was
their money right there wasn't anything
interesting to really talk about right
and then we went to the after party i
was still married then and i'll tell you
i'm not going to say on your broadcast
who was there
but there were some famous people there
okay and uh
and some famous wealthy people
and one of this famous wealthy person's
girlfriend
put molly in my wife's mouth
unexpectedly
she was just talking one more like this
bloop get out of here she's like what
did you what did you would you yeah what
with her fingers
yeah it was a weird it was a weird night
and um what what did you did your wife
freak out did she spit it out no she
insisted then that i do the same thing
but well that makes sense
weirdly that doesn't make sense by that
time i was just exhausted and tired of
all these people and i was like why am i
here god the last thing you want to do
is is molly when you're in a group like
that that you're not comfortable with
jesus
i
i wasn't uncomfortable like i really
didn't care at that point it's more like
a social observation at some point so
here's the other weird part
we go to some it was half residential
half
uh apartments high dollar apartments
the first place we go to is someone's
huge [ __ ] apartment that's way up and
well appointed since san francisco
and then
slowly people are leaving this room
going to the real
party
and then somehow we got to that place
and then everybody ends up showing up
there like like who got invited last
it's just weird
weird and you know what it was it was
immature
yeah it sounds it it sounds really image
but but like you said i mean if you it
can be like a fun
observational um experience if you have
a partner like you were with your wife
at the time you said and so
in that sense it must have been kind of
fun like you feel like you're on like
rich people like douchey safari or
something yes
yes but at that point it's like i'm not
doing one of these again i've done two
of those rich people roasts and they're
just always kind of shitty
yeah oh god well but so this thing is
different i love that name um what kind
of stuff would champ champ kind say oh
champ will do the so champ would be
later in the show and it's we also have
a different background i can show you
uh-huh
so right now dave has like a hollywood
it's like the um kind of an art geckoey
hollywood
background
here look there's the oh you got the uh
channel for the action news yeah
and then this is for the fake commercial
we do for them oh it's a car use cars
and then when you're interviewing todd
packer there's that oh the office
background yeah yeah and this is uh i
start always from a hotel room in reno
nevada in reno this is great we did a
holiday party this year so that was that
one oh my god the north pole this is
this is typically home base just because
uh for the show because it reminds them
like oh it's from hollywood
but then so champ champs news will be
whatever's going on with your company
one of them was talking about like this
some some company in
indiana
um
they have a notorious thing is there's
no parking for the employees
so something like
half the staff at blah blah blah company
was late today because they but not
because there was a wreck on the blah
blah freeway because there was no
parking come on
company get your stuff together
maybe you guys should invite invest in
bikes you know the chinese may work [ __ ]
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
twice we've done two different companies
that both had had a water failure uh-huh
in their building so that was you put
that in the news well what's great i
mean we had just been talking about like
offensive i was wondering about
potentially offensive things that you
might say what's great about champ and
todd packer is that it's in the
character you you you can probably get
away with so much more yeah because
those guys are uh i mean that's
if they're offensive people or their
horrible horrible people yeah
is that liberty that must be fun to get
to play i mean i i so rarely have gotten
to do that but right you don't you don't
ever play awful nah very rarely i've
gotten to and it's always been such a
release there's something so freeing
about it like like i've been
sitting on all this i've been like
repressing all this stuff yeah certainly
the thing we did together when we met
i'm thinking about waiting um
you were you got to be ridiculous i mean
you were so ridiculous that uh i i'm
you're probably so sick of me saying
this but every time i see you i feel
like we talk about this thing that you
did which is my favorite which i have to
tell people um
you started saying uh you started adding
do you know you know what i'm gonna say
so if dave started adding the letter g
to
so words that began with vowels
in these scenes you were doing it in
scenes so you'd say like
all right every everyone
[Music]
there's a take i don't think there's a
take i can see it in the movie
occasionally like i haven't seen it in a
while but they'll be like they had to
use wide shots because i couldn't get
through my close-ups with you because
you kept doing it
everyone we had fun i don't know how
much people improvised in this in that
movie but you and i he allowed
rob allowed you and i to improvise quite
a bit a lot yeah so much fun you're one
of those people and it's so rare that
can
they can play something so they can be
big in a scene and make a choice like
that and it's still real you get away
with it because it's still grounded and
um
to this day like it's one of the hardest
i've ever laughed and uh i think it's
subtle in the movie but i don't i don't
know where you got that from but it was
just a [ __ ] i thought it was a bit
you and i started doing at some point
now maybe and it's almost like we're
trying to [ __ ] with each other a little
bit in the scene yes all right let's see
what we got going here here
[Laughter]
i don't know what else to say
that's so good
you say to me at some point okay real
mature what was my main character's name
um
damn damn dan
yeah real mature it is mature
yes
that i we had fun i remember that
finished yeah
here's how it went yourself went down
yeah
oh it was so funny all because you
rejected you rejected my overture
of making you a manager so i was so hurt
that's right it must be fun i mean that
character character like that is so
small like so small and petty yes and
it's such a funny juxtaposition because
you are such a
large warm i mean naturally you are
the opposite of that kind of guy um it
must be
fun to do
i had worked in a lot of restaurants
through college and so
that was kind of a
cherry picking some personality traits
from a couple of those guys
and so that's how it for me it was just
like i i will say that i do remember my
audition and i made the casting director
cry
so i thought
i've got this and then they went out to
two other actors and then came back to
me oh did they really
how do you oh do you know who yeah okay
you don't have to say i'm curious though
i'm so curious
oh my god that's i'll tell you it was
jaymore and uh jeremy piven god you know
that piven the pivot one sounds familiar
yeah i think i did know that they
offered it isn't that funny well what
was your name casper mccarthy mcganny
annie right
mccartney yeah
and i remember she was crying during the
audition and i thought oh my god i got
this
and then you don't
yeah and then they already had they
already had offers out and you're like
oh wow
have you ever had have you ever had an
audition that was [ __ ] amazing and
you didn't get it wedding crashers
people people are probably sick of
hearing me say the story uh i don't know
if i've told it but but same lisa beach
and sarah katzman i think it's the only
time it happened
either they both cried or one of them
but they stopped the tape they people in
the room were laughing so hard
i was auditioning for todd the son in
that movie and um
and i just thought oh i was hugging the
i mean they were hugging me what's you
in fact it was funny because they were
checking what are your fate are you
available tell us you're available
and i was supposed to do waiting so i
said well i'm committed to this thing oh
can you get out have you signed it was
that oh my god
i would have much rather have done i
mean i hate to say this because no of
course of course who played the part
so tier o'donnell got the part who
hadn't done anything i don't think he
had an agent and kier and i are are to
this to this day best best friends very
very close yeah i got a standing ovation
and didn't get it no [ __ ] for for what
for what
uh the end of the world movie with john
cusack they already had an offer out to
woody harrelson oh okay isn't that funny
it's a it's a crazy guy in the camper
who talks about the end of the world he
finally the earth crashes below him but
they already had an offer out to woody
and they'll do this
you know if the negotiations aren't
going how they want yes they will have
other actors they'll keep auditioning
just to let the actor know we do have a
second choice they they have leverage
yeah exactly yeah but to me i was like
well [ __ ] i've got this
this that's mine i called my agent on
the in the car immediately like well
book that it goes um
they already have a uh an offer out
so which just means they knew that in
the room yeah which lets them be even
more free to applaud a performance that
no one will ever see yeah yeah
almost like now you you look back at
that and you think well what might have
been behind that effusive reaction was a
little bit of sympathy you know maybe
they were pitying you for yes exactly
and the thing is you know these things
happen it doesn't matter if you have a
good audition you bank it you always
remember that like in in in our business
always like michael jordan would say
always focus on your best performance
not
your bad performance
and that's what we need to do as actors
especially yeah like if i go and think
about the shitty auditions i had i'm
gonna have shitty auditions yeah but you
know if you bank the good ones like
that's a great memory for me whether it
happened or not like i'm the sad thing
is i'm casting as a negative a little
bit but still it was a triumph
you know and ultimately like that job
wouldn't have made a dent in my career
uh well now that we're talking about
auditions dave i'm curious i do have to
mention something about uh
something not being seen uh i don't know
if you talked about this on your show
your performance in anchorman one i
think we've talked about i don't know if
it's on i don't know if you've talked
about it on this i think we have now
this is the first time we met yeah was
on that set
you [ __ ] killed it
you and fred willard it's such a funny
[ __ ] scene
multiple scenes so [ __ ] amazing you
were goddamn perfect you were [ __ ]
perfect
i was remember thinking who's this kid
god damn he's good
and um
sadly cut from the [ __ ] picture it
was extra disappointing only because it
ended up being a classic it's just such
a perfect comedy i think it's one of my
favorites and it's one of those rare
movies that whenever it's on i have to
watch yeah i got to watch the rest of it
um and did you know i mean was that a
job that you think i mean obviously you
knew a bunch of those guys going in i'm
sure you knew mckay and will that you
know them from snl right um
but did you how what was that audition
process like talk about you know high
stakes
will and adam are friends
so i understand their humor
so in my mind i knew
chemically what they wanted
right i'm pretty sure i auditioned for
champ and brian fantana oh oh oh oh i'm
proud of that because people just think
that i was given that part but i wasn't
uh yeah i auditioned it came down to me
and three other guys who who i don't
know who they are
but um
it's a bit of psychology so i'm sure you
can understand like if adam adam and
will wanted me right yeah but they can't
tell the producer this is our choice
because if they did you're pretty much
sure the producer is not going to choose
you
yeah they're going to want they just
gave them four the four people up for
the role
and the guy was watching them and mine
after money goes why not that guy
and they're like yeah
and so smart of will and adam that's
really yeah so they called me and they
said look we're not supposed to call you
but your agent's gonna be calling you
this is going to happen but we're so
excited we want you to know you got it
so
part of it was like i think they're
proud of their friend too like oh yeah
you did a good job because you know
when you start you just assume your
friends can give you jobs they can yeah
right yeah yeah there's two things
number one you assume that your friends
can give you a job and number two you
think your friends should give you a job
yeah right those things are true
yeah
oftentimes they can't give you a job and
guess what they shouldn't give you a
[ __ ] job it should be it should be
because you have to be the person
explain to people the psychology behind
will and adam not saying something to
the producer well what
because
like like probably most jobs
uh if the if you tell the boss you're
you're under the boss and you tell the
boss what you think what decision you
think should be made it's that simple
psychology
i think human nature is i must decide
and the best way for me to decide for a
smaller mind and i'm not saying this
producer had a smaller mind but
you know the best chess game to play is
let's let this thing play out neutrally
yeah because if you put your thumb on
the scale
that human nature is going to be and
it's a power position and a different
people they play different power games
for no good reason right other than just
like nope i'll decide
what i do remember about that set was
was the freedom that they gave everybody
to improvise and weren't there takes
that were totally unscripted just like
go out and
add them and sure judd would yell
stuff behind the monitor and
yeah
what they would typically do every scene
was they'd get at least three good takes
and then mckay would yell let's let the
squirrel out of the bag and then he
improvise
i argue that that's what makes the film
a little bit better is because there's a
different chemical attunement that's
happening because look actors go uh-huh
uh-huh you're lying you're done my line
uh-huh but if you're improvising you
actually which is the point of
improvising is please simply listen
yeah right which is actually the actor's
only job
you have to actually listen because now
you're really tuning your your
instrument a little higher
right like i got to be [ __ ] super
dialed in here if i want to play if i
want to get if i want to get some screen
time let me [ __ ] eat
let me get ready and and you're and
you're dialed in with uh you you have to
be present with these people who are
genius who are the best uh
yep and well um i love the movie so much
and i'm such a nerdy fan of it that i
could go through
line by line but um
the one that really sticks out is uh
the the through line that you are
secretly in love with him and and not so
secretly that you are where did that was
that in the script already was that
stuff that lately it was not in the
script i i think i think i can't
remember exactly why but
it kind of became apparent to me
that there's something going on
between
yeah yeah um
and
have you watched wake up ron burgundy uh
well i was gonna say there's a great
extended scene in that you have where
you go on and on about wanting to move
in with him and oh my god
yeah and yeah you you've thought about
it so much the the domestic oh that's
all that's on his mind yes yeah you
realize that champ is deeply desperately
in love with ron
uh
and they're ignoring it the best is
their their reaction is that they're
this to ignore such blatant
i mean you're going out you're being
like you're professing your love in such
a like uh
what like overdone way okay take it easy
champ there's a lot it was it's very
funny it's so uncomfortable and it goes
on for so long i was i was deeply
disappointed that did not make the film
yeah i bet i know
because i thought well that's my scene
oh
yeah but yeah whatever well there's a
similarly corel has a great scene on
that yes well this is going to be a
great promotion for wake up ron burgundy
i know right
he's got the the which is the audition
scene where he's talking about the um
the burrito with chocolate chips on it
comes out to be
a coffee is that a
brick is that a coffee filter so is he
he just found trash that he's eating
do you remember that scene oh my god
i remember filming that scene it was the
last scene on a friday afternoon and we
could not we could not
hold it together that what if anything
should be seen it's the outtakes from
that scene
no one could hold it together
folks what happens is uh we're uh we're
in a cafeteria of the of the news
building plotting our
whatever revenge on veronica
corningstone
and it's myself and
champ ron burgundy and brick and we're
talking about what we're going to do to
her and then
then ron notices that that brick is
eating a coffee filter
with a bunch of trash in it like
yes and he said um
brick what are you eating he says i'm
eating one of these delicious burritos
he goes
where did you get that i got it from
that bin at the end of the
that's the garbage can brick
[Laughter]
but he's eating he's eating a coffee
filter with cigarette butts and coffee
grounds and assorted pieces of trash in
it and just blindly eating along of
course it's filled with chocolate cake
and that's what's great about that movie
is that it they let those moments um
it's like they knew what they had with
those moments and they let them play out
so that's how i felt about being around
all you guys it was such an exciting
job to get that like the fact that it
didn't work out you know it sucks but
it's it's just to have done that to have
had that experience i i feel very
fortunate
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and would
shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
i'm very resistant to working out and
doing activities and a thing that is
actually this is going to sound nuts
that a thing that has encouraged me to
do them is how much i love my socks that
doesn't sound nuts oh because does it
have that effect on you well because i
know what socks you're talking about
yeah they're bombas so you can't
overstate the comfort and the
impressiveness of these socks they're
just so fun to wear because they also
have the grip on the bottom so you can
wear them around the house i've never
had ankle socks that that fit well that
don't slip into your shoes you know they
they always stay up right around the rim
they're also fun to wear i don't know
how else to explain they're like here my
best endorsement for bombus is that i've
never before thought so much about the
socks i'm wearing right they all just
sort of seem like socks to me until
bombus they have temperature regulating
vents that allow
cool air flowing how would you invent
that but whoever did is a genius they
prevent overheating they come in
different styles for every sport for
every pair of bombus socks you buy
bombus the company donates a pair to
someone in need and thus far they've
donated over 45 million pairs of socks
which arguably that's the most
impressive thing about it it is we
really bury the lead go to bombus.com
long today and get 20 off your first
order that's b o m
b a s yeah
dot com slash long for 20 off bombus.com
long
hello again
[Music]
i think you and i have worked together
four times i think so anchorman one yeah
waiting one and two and then currently
in f is for family where we never get to
do anything together oh god i gotta tell
you dave did i tell you that after so
you're that you're you play my favorite
character on emphasis for family it's a
uh it's a brilliant voice because it's
it doesn't sound that much like you but
it sounds
it's so evocative the voice itself it's
and it goes along with this massively
obese man uh who's constantly shoving
food in his mouth
well i have two things to say about that
my question is
are you eating while you're doing that
no your voice is so good in it it really
does match the absurdity of that that
art of the animation does that guy
remind you you mentioned when you're
playing dan and waiting that you had it
was an amalgamation of certain bosses is
that guy like anybody that you knew
i don't think so to me that was just all
there on the page
this guy is just a huge pain body right
and he's
also cruel and it's another horrible
person i mean i do yeah
people very well oh he's like monstrous
he's a monster he absolutely is yeah and
the fact that you know that's set in the
70s so they will say things like he eats
an entire candy truck and then blames it
on puerto ricans
like what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
jesus christ yes i was kidnapped by
puerto ricans they forced me to eat all
this candy
it's so it's such great satire because
it really like is such a fun way to
reveal how gross the racism and misogyny
of that time was such um
it's just dialed up a little bit you
know like i i can almost hear somebody
from that time
saying a version of that
once i think it happened more than maybe
twice um
i i i went in for a recording now of
course we're we're doing it remotely but
um i remember going in and being so
disappointed that i just missed you
uh this was in la and um i put on the
headsets i put on the thing to record
did i tell you this oh and
it was wet
it was wet sopping wet
yeah stretch like a snake
i always assume they change the heads i
when i
perform
i did even in cartoons i get very
physical
especially because
bob pogo is such a big physical thing
usually by the time i'm done a session i
can't even speak anymore because he
always yells too oh my god i don't know
how you do that voice will you do a
little bit of what you do just for
people who haven't heard it okay
you're the best part of the chicken is
don't you
where's that goddamn biscuit i had
another
[Music]
so to me i get very physical when i do
him
yes and so i just assume they must
clearly swap out the headsets well i
think they do usually i think maybe they
missed
them
yeah since coven dave i don't think i've
ever talked to you about your year on
snl why um first of all how did you get
it how exciting is you had come from
second city um which i know is like a
fairly
you know one of the pipelines to snl
right so it must have been a thrill to
get it
but what was that year like well if i
can tell you i i kind of thought snl had
run its course quite frankly by the time
i got the show and now it's still on
this was in year 20. it was year 20. and
i i thought in the show the year before
had had a really tough year that's when
the uh the new york magazine
it declared saturday night dead
and uh there was kind of they
certain people had left the show and it
was just this is like 94 95 94 yeah
94.95 they point to the nancy kerrigan
episode as one that was uh
especially not good
um
i'm just re recounting what has been
reported so yeah i felt like [ __ ] i get
on the show after it's done in my mind a
little bit i always wanted to be on that
show now the problem was i had come from
an ensemble
at second city i'm by nature an ensemble
person i'm not necessarily competitive
with other actors i assume that if i'm
there of course we're all going to
succeed
my success doesn't isn't predicated on
you not succeeding that's not the way my
mind works um and i assume that the best
interest of every producer at that show
would be to make sure that the entire
cast succeeds but that's not it at all
the the the the atmosphere there is
sacre swim
you know you better [ __ ] bring it
it's like why wouldn't someone help
everybody do their best it's really a
[ __ ] up
approach
pretty stupid um yeah but anyway i don't
suffer fools gladly
and uh there's several people that i
didn't quite agree with
there and i don't i'm not good at hiding
how i feel about people
and so there's one person in particular
who i'll tell you at another time who i
think engineered my demise two people
apparently one of them still i guess
they still both work i've often thought
if i ever write a book i'm going to call
this person and go hammer i'm going to
talk about you
just so you know
but this neither of these people have a
great deal of respect
from other people in comedy which is
fine with me and uh yeah i would think
that he knows that in the bottom of his
heart but my biggest mistake was they'd
asked me to do a gerald talk show
that year there had been so many talk
shows like every other sketch was a talk
show and i i said that's what's wrong
with this show we need more sketches
they weren't asking me
that's where this kid from missouri
doesn't quite hear what's being said
what do you think about a gerald talk
show and you know what looking back at
it it would have worked perfectly gerald
tibbens on a talk show it's almost like
before
between two ferns because gerald's that
type of person that would not be kind to
yes
it would be funny i'm thinking about it
i mean it's it's because yeah he would
say what was ever whatever was on his
mind exactly would probably alienate the
um
that would be the point to take power
away from and alienate the guest and
then
i thought about later and then insist
that um we do a scene from whatever
movie the the uh or tv show the actor's
been in and i do their part
that's funny that's funny what um i just
read that that you were only on for a
year yeah what happened was lauren
wanted to bring me back
except that year was the first year mad
tv
and uh howard stern had a late night
show on television oh okay that was that
year yes so there was competition for
snl for the first time in late night
with comedy their ratings dipped a
little bit which gave west coast some
power
and there was apparently one west coast
person that didn't like me
and decided that i needed to go do you
know who that
is one of one of them was don olmeier
and the other apparently was gary
considine uh how do you find these
things out
someone told me
oh someone from the show told me
oh really yeah well and there was
another producer on the show who i won't
say
i mentioned something about him
my opinion of him and it got back to him
because another rat think writer told on
me but i should have said it to his
[ __ ] face i guess
well you
you seem like as as
kind of person you are as and you
there's just such a generous person it
you had mentioned like well i'm a guy
from i'm a kid from missouri and i i
tell people how i feel and you were also
very people might not realize how big
you're just physically imposing
so i i don't i don't imagine
that people often say things to your
face i'm sure if they have problems with
you it's probably gone right it
probably gets back to you in a more
circuitous way yes yes and then of
course then i then i stew
which doesn't help which doesn't help
yeah yeah it's too bad it hurt a lot and
it was a mistake on their part and i
think they know that and it's one of
those things like lauren
wanted to keep me and he i i got a
meeting with him which people tell me
never happens
but it really was his hands were tied
west coast wanted changes and for
whatever reason it was me you've been in
everything every type of movie piranha
and comedies and you know um very
serious you've done such your body of
work is is so varied um
and is that it was that deliberate or is
it just like i'm gonna go where the wind
takes me
a little bit of both uh as you know i
have five kids so a lot of it is i have
to work
yeah yeah and look you know and part of
it is is it's kind of like the work
ethic my my dad gave me i started
working for my dad when i was seven
years old
and so to me it's like well just just
work
but your dad's a hollywood producer
that's of course
[Laughter]
my dad was a manufacturer of livestock
trailers in tipton
specifically for a guy
he was a big guy
yeah yeah and did you so you worked did
you so you did you have a farm a turkey
farm no no he was a manufacturer he
built the trailers oh the livestock oh
okay yeah livestock trailers for turkeys
have you ever seen turkeys go down the
highway in big trailers
probably made in tipton missouri
and no kidding what how did he get into
how does one get into something like
that well here's the story um it's a
very small town my dad grew up a farmer
uh and then he decided to be a
manufacturer he was building uh small
farm implements and he was building
something for for hogs called farrowing
crates and what that is when a female
hog has uh piglets um
she will roll over on her piglets
so
when the when the piglets need to feed
this stands her up so the piglets can
feed and she won't roll over and mash
them
so when they're done feeding then they
would let them let them go he was doing
that and then uh
their friend virgil clee thermos yes
real name
virgil clether one more time virgil
virgil
virgil klee thermos amazing yes they had
nine kids um i'm only from six where i'm
from a lot of catholics in this small
town
six was a normal number of kids
oh my god
six six you don't six you go okay six
nine you go jesus nine
oh my god and and three you go what is
wrong with them yes well you must be a
protestant
virgil clee thermos has a turkey farm
back then turkeys were outdoors not in
turkey barns there used to be what they
would call hogwire around the turkeys
and that is a larger gauge fencing with
larger
gapping right but they would use a
staple to hammer it into a large
staple nail to hamlet hammered to the
post one of those came out and took out
virgil clether mrs eye so virgil's in
the hospital they need guys to go out
and load the the turkeys into the
trailers
to send to the processing plant and my
dad went out to help uh and he noticed
the crates that they were loading these
turkeys in were terrible and he was like
i could build a better
turkey crate than these
so that's what he got into that business
he started building turkey
yeah oh my god it's it's amazing dave
something you said struck me that um
you go from
this community where every like you said
everybody helps each other out there's
no thought of well what's he gonna give
me and
well he's got more livestock you just go
and help out your neighbor and then you
just to juxtapose that with the
environment that you described at snl
it's um
so far
justin i'm from tipton missouri two
thousand people
i'm on saturday night live
i gotta say i'm probably the biggest
hillbilly that's ever been on that show
well but not but and yet there are so
many people that i've we've talked about
this on the show so many people funny
people talented people from
that part of the country uh
we talked about with cat mcnamara when
she was on
and
paul rudd and you and and stone street
sedakis stone sedakis right i mean it's
the the young lady who's also on the
show now the blonde heidi heidi on snl
oh she's from there yeah i didn't know
that uh they well they grow them they
grow them uh funny and uh good
good-hearted uh and and you guys are all
you all belong to a great charity called
um the big slick right you bet you do
that as well
um
you go down you help out the local
children's hospital do you do that every
year you go and play in the game well we
have um obviously we didn't do it last
year
next year is uh in question and because
the nature of things we might step it
down to just a large dinner so but if it
happens uh maybe you're
maybe you're amenable
i would love to i um you know seth
herzog keeps saying to me well why don't
you do it and i would say i don't know i
i would i would like no one's ever asked
me
i'd be so down to do that i love it i
love the idea of it and i love playing
baseball this is my son charlie i don't
know if you guys have met no
charlie yeah what's up you're you're
huge the last time i saw you was in a
christmas card remember the one you guys
did with the grizzly bear
oh yeah yeah
did you do one this year um i don't
think so your mother did yeah my mom
probably put one together
how old are you now charlie
21
and he's acting he's he's studying
acting no kidding where where we're at
um i just did a year at the american
academy of dramatic arts oh great
the one in new york
oh in west hollywood oh good for you and
he's been doing other well i have to do
it online now a bunch of different
different different ones online i just
finished a couple different online
classes charlie sorry to to pepper you
with these questions how tall are you
uh 640.
oh my god that's crazy charlie's leaning
down in dave's zoom shot
i'm not telling you guys
he can only act with me he's so tall
well we can cast you with your dad i
guess yeah
yeah it's well it's nice to see it
charlie yeah nice to meet you
yeah yeah oh wow dave that's crazy 21 my
god
they were toddlers they were little kids
when when we yep
when we did yep oh my god that's freaky
he's a what is that like you have cr
are your kids do you watch football i'm
picturing you just like sunday is just
like a bunch of techners going crazy
they're they're into the nba
oh really i know i try to get them into
football they're all nba maybe charlie
knows charlie knows everything about the
nba i know a little bit through him i
i'm i'm a fan but i'm not a huge fan
like i love the nfl
but my kids are not i'm like ah they're
all chiefs fans none of them well
sergeant is kind of
but i know that he likes the nba more i
know he does
he doesn't want to hurt you by by making
it clear
maybe you went so
just because you're such a rabid
chiefs fan
is that fair to say no
i mean you were like the most famous
yeah yeah well no i mean you know
wriggle and rud we all go to the games
and stone street of course
i have a nice jacket
you do but you are the way have you ever
seen taran kill him at a rams game have
you ever seen that not at a game i mean
he gets so in he's similar he's the only
one that i can compare to you in terms
of their
and i guess wriggle riggle really like
the two of you guys really go really go
for it but um
what was it like to finally be at have
to finally win the super bowl
oh
it was pretty good talk to each other
that whole season that whole season was
amazing yeah and uh look for me even to
know the organization you know to have
met the players and to get some access
like that for me is incredible because
i've been a fan since i was 10.
so back in the 70s before football was
what it is now
you wouldn't always get the game on
television if you're in tipton missouri
you only got three channels right so
the time i remember was uh christmas day
the chiefs were playing uh the dolphins
it's one of the uh the first longest
game in history three over times and the
chiefs lost uh jan standard wide right
oh but my my cousins my cousins were
from kansas city and were all in my
grandmother's living room watching the
game and that's when i really started
getting into it so you weathered all
those storms you were like a fan
throughout that time and so it must have
been really
i mean that's what that's what probably
made that the sweetest to go to the
super bowl and oh yeah
well the sweetest actually i'll tell you
my brother uh turned 60 last january
22nd
and that's the day i got confirmation
from the chiefs that they were going to
let me
buy from their package oh wow and so i
could call my brother on his 60th
birthday and say hey i'm taking you to
the super bowl oh that's so for me that
was that was the best on top of the best
missouri or missouri will you settle
this for us for me it's always for me
personally it's always been missouri
just because i knew
missouri to me always sounded dumb like
willfully ignorant
and i'm like i'm not going to be dumb
but it's but a lot of people from
missouri
missouri will say
i mean it's not like they correct you
missouri yeah i i just it's not me yeah
okay yeah no i i i you know i just i
always knew well that's not the way
you're supposed to say it yeah which is
that also goes hand in hand with my last
name
it's k o e c h and e r nowhere in the
english language does the o e make a
short e sound
so i would never say
well
i have 36 first cousins on my dad's side
yeah so how could i change it
i didn't have the temerity to go you
[ __ ] hillbillies are saying it wrong
it should be coachner at best
the
right so you could change to either
k-i-r or k-u-r
right oh yeah or put an s-h in there or
change it to k-e-c-k-n-e-r
because that's how it's pronounced
that's true kachner i've never it's
funny i've never questioned it
i've never i've never questioned it
so when you and when you went to second
city where did you have any missouri
acts do you have a missourian accent
that you had to lose i'm sure i did in
my mind of course i didn't but i think
there's
the missouri accent it's flat
it's it's not interesting it's almost a
hick accent because it if anything in
missouri it's just kind of flying like
this there's nothing interesting about
it now
alabama you got a little something to
play with right now mississippi you got
it more to play with now george you got
something else now in south carolina you
got this pinch now north carolina got a
little less pinch but you know how it
goes throughout my whole section right
but then you go to missouri and it's
just kind of flat and you might just
fall asleep having to listen to someone
talk from missouri
how did how did you do how did you do
that those the regionalisms so well i
just from traveling around
yeah when chicago you start noticing
because you're you know your accent's
different so you're hearing all these
beautiful accents there and i worked in
an off track betting parlor once and
they had several people from the south
that i'd noticed oh these are all
different
alabama
georgia and mississippi were all
different i was like oh well that's
interesting and of course texas texas
you know texas is just australian flat
elongated let's hear that have you from
texas now australia is not too far away
from texas is it now right right is it
now right yeah that's right you know
texas you think of matt mcconnell hey
for texas you speed that up and pinch
you just let this australia again that's
where i've always thought of it right
that's all right yeah yeah there's a
there's a good documentary called the
story of english
uh and it takes the scots from the east
coast down through the area of
appalachia and you see how all of those
southern accents were actually part of
different parts of uh england yeah well
i wanna i'm writing this down and you
can hear it if you think scots and
kentuckians
and the appalachians you can if you you
can
i'm sure i'm sure it's somewhere right
i had it once on a vhs but it's been
years since i've looked at it it's so
funny my last question i didn't even
christian had written these questions um
why did you thought christian and i were
uh twins
i i don't know why i thought on one of
your posts
i i i i guess because you look so much a
lot alike yeah you are the same exact
height nearly right pretty much yeah
yeah he might be a little taller and i
guess just the way you guys [ __ ] with
each other
i guess august i guess you guys who
talked about each other as the other
brother
for some reason a couple of years ago in
my head that you're twins it's not a
crazy thing to think yeah and then we
have an older brother who um
i'm actually closer in age with than i
am with christian uh but we probably
looked yeah i i look more similar to um
the little brother
who's older christian or you so i'm
older by three years three and a half
years uh oh so it was a it was a it was
uh a stain on him that i would think
that he's three years old yeah yeah
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
you know how much i love a segment
this one is brought to you by bud light
seltzer's new retro summer pack do you
know what i really miss about being a
kid
i miss
the thrill of trying to catch fireflies
oh man so the only problem with catching
fireflies as a kid is that you couldn't
pair it with something as fun as
drinking a bud light seltzer yeah well
now you can now you can have both and
you can have a little bit of the um
nostalgic
fun summer vibes element
if you want a bud light seltzer because
now they have new retro summer pack it's
a limited edition bud light seltzer
retro summer pack it has uh it's a
tie-dye pack which you know there's
nothing more retro than that and there's
three throwback flavors that are
reminiscent of summers spent on the
boardwalk by the pool family barbecues
you know summer things they're each
refreshing in different ways there's
something about the blue raspberry that
is like that's the most instantly
recognizable as nostalgic my favorite is
still the summer
yeah so grab some friends grab some
tunes and enjoy the vibes well you don't
grab tunes you play some tunes oh you're
right you could play friends too you can
grab something that plays tunes yeah
that's true so get it delivered right to
your door find a retailer near you at
budlight.com
delivery or what else can you do well
you do the old-fashioned way you can go
to your local neighborhood grocery
convenience or liquor store and just get
your hands on them or however you choose
to get them into your possession
[Music]
dave what is your most commonly used
emoji would you say when you're texting
do you use them i would say hearts to my
kids
ah
that's nice yeah you say and i can't
believe you have 21 year old that's the
oldest charlie's 21 marvel's 19 sergeant
and audrey are 14 and eve is nine
oh my god sergeant and audrey it's so
funny i'm just picturing that
that christmas card um
they were awesome
little kids dude
it's interesting that's a lot every day
every day you're like wow wow
wow
yeah and and i know and then you think
well your parents had even more
i know one more
guy well you remember how we had ours
um
uh lee lost her uterus with charlie
she still had her ovaries
on the outside of the uterus she had a
rare thing called placenta acrita after
the birth the the placenta they
discovered had grown into the uterus and
so it's just ripping it apart she's just
bleeding so they had to take her uterus
the ovaries are on the outside of the
uterus so then they told us you can
still have your own kids through
surrogacy
so we they took em
eggs from her ovaries and we pulled come
from my [ __ ] it was about five or six of
us got together and we just we yanked on
that thing
just thanks a lot for asking me
you know i would have i would have liked
to have been included i didn't know you
that well
um so anyway uh we created 11 embryos
used the first three got her daughter
margot froze the other eight into two
groups of four
we had margo and sar margo and charlie
and i was kind of like all right
and then uh
my wife was uh by the way dave just
stepped out like a like a blackjack
dealer yeah yeah um and then my wife
insisted that those are children those
are babies i was like oh wow the things
you don't talk about
okay
so
that's quite an assumption uh
i know so we worked we worked through
the had the we thought out the first
group before got the twins oh my god the
family that's that was it that was the
hard part justin when the family double
the kids doubled overnight it's like
holy [ __ ] oh my god you have two then
you have four that was i was like wow
i didn't know that this last last group
of four and like well let's see and then
we got eve so i mean oh obviously a
blessing but it's not something i would
have predicted yeah
yeah like when you were younger that
when you were thinking about maybe being
a family man well i'd always thought uh
early there was a guy who was actually
my neighbor was a science teacher uh he
did his um as i look back on this he
kind of overstepped his bounds but he
said that um
because of the nature of overpopulation
of the planet you should really replace
only you you and your spouse
which you can't really teach in school
but this was a catholic school yeah you
should like that i thought it made sense
like well of course just don't be
selfish just replace your spouse of
course that's that's the same thing to
do
yes but i but then faced with this
proposition like well these are
children
in their mind i could never have given
them away
right
you know because you can do that with
embryos like these are embryos it's not
just eggs frozen eggs these are frozen
embryos oh so i i couldn't i couldn't
ever go okay let's donate these to a
family that can't have kids i i couldn't
do that
and so you know just psychologically
knowing that they would be out there
they were from you they were couldn't i
couldn't yeah let me personally know
yeah
were they raised catholic dave are you
still practicing
[Laughter]
as a matter of course
catholic schools are cheaper than
private other private schools oh yeah
yes
these days folks in los angeles the
price of a private school is thirty
thousand dollars per child uh catholic
school is about five grand and per child
wow
wow so that's affordable so for that
reason they went to catholics they
became very uh
orthodox you know what i nope of course
not i would always say whenever they
come home with uh you know the
doctrines i'd say well that's one story
there's a lot of stories uh for the
purposes of this test that's exactly how
you're going to answer
but
when you want to talk about things we
can always talk about things so yeah
well and that's not what you grew up
with right like you're you're oh no my
parents were very very catholic very
catholic okay oh i would say their
outlook on life was catholicism uh dave
just really quick uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play
i guess football did you play in high
school i did to know a result
i was uh i was very thin when i when i
was a freshman in high school i was five
foot tall 99 pounds me too 89 pounds
four foot four foot ten eighty nine
pounds no i mean
i'm from a very small town so of course
i made the football team and any other
town i wouldn't have made the team oh
yeah so you were like uh defensive back
yeah i think so but i didn't play uh and
by the time i was a senior i was 510 150
so and i was alignment so i there's you
know i'm not making an impact at all oh
my god wait when did you grow when did
you have your growth spurt i kept
growing through college holy [ __ ] i know
i was i was i was born in august so when
i went to college i was actually 17. oh
my god dave how you're six four as well
right like charlie six two six two oh
your son's well that must have been
weird when he surpassed you see it
coming you see it coming you're like oh
[ __ ]
oh my god and my son sergeant is now
5-11 and he's 14. oh my god don't tell
me what to do dad
if you could have uh if you could have
one snack food for the rest of your life
what would it be uh uh uh unsalted
cashews oh my god
you and um allison brie okay yeah if you
could uh what's your favorite movie
sequel of all time we were talking about
anchorman 2 which i love i love
increment too
i do too um sequel so monty python life
of brian is not a sequel to holy grail
so i can't choose that one no no but i
love them both oh i i like the vacation
movies oh okay yeah like your so it
would be european vacation is the second
one christmas vacation oh it is i don't
know i should know this so there's
vacation
uh-huh there's national lampoon's
vacation that's it and then i thought
then european vacation was that second i
think so i could be wrong but let's say
that i i think yeah vacation okay what's
your go-to karaoke song probably uh turn
the page by bob seeger anything bob
seeger's in my range uh-huh oh yeah no
that or um i like tonight's the night by
uh uh rod stewart because it's so wrong
oh god yeah it's wrong yeah
spread your wings and let me come inside
no don't say don't say a word my virgin
child no just let your inhibitions run
wild the secret is about to unfold relax
and let's something explode because
he's he's sneaking in her back door and
it's like are you [ __ ] kidding me
this is rod stewart
this is right
tonight
wait i gotta lick this stay away from my
windows stay away from my back door too
disconnect the telephone line relax baby
and draw that blind okay so what's going
on so back door means um i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna go uh up your chute
tonight but uh just kind of let you and
also disconnect your telephone so what
you can't call where you're in distress
yes that's right that's really creepy
it's a creepy break-in and he's going to
have his way with a virgin go ahead oh
my god
you're right come on come on angel my
heart's on fire don't deny your man's
desire you'd be a fool to stop this tide
spread your wings and let me come inside
yes
he's coaching he's he's grooming oh
don't say a word my virgin child yeah
you my god
who knew that uh
when you listen to like oh my so for me
if i do that karaoke song i do
commentary while i'm singing
like like the woke version yes two
nights the night everything's gonna be
all right uh
then uh no one's gonna ah
there's something about some no no one
can stop us now nobody i love you girl
ain't nobody's gonna stop us now then
i'll go not your brother not your mother
not your father no one is gonna stop me
virgin
you will not deny me
oh my god oh my god
oh my god i had no idea these lyrics
were so
disgusting um who was your first
celebrity crush
linda evans
oh that was quick linda evans yeah and
did you ever have occasion to meet her
in life no no no
um
yeah it's 70s then it would be yeah
dallas
dallas right right
um bo derek i remember really loving and
uh sure
and then i worked with you oh derek and
linda evans both married to the same man
maybe that's why i thought about her
john derek yes
uh well first john evans
thank you um wow i did not know that uh
well he
well
lucky him
lucky
uh if if you had to get a tattoo
do you have tattoos no yes i do i've got
uh a heart with my ex-wife in it and my
kids all around it oh that's cool that's
cool i'm sorry i'm gonna get that gotta
get that changed it'll be that'll be a
tough day for the kids
do you know what i mean like dad oh
you're changing the kids
well no
[Laughter]
there you go oh it's big he's showing me
yeah yeah
so i think we'll just listen to your
podcast
it's the entire show the the side of my
arm margot oh that's cool it's very
it's very truckery actually
absolutely yeah yeah so i just had hers
then put the harder on it than the kids
okay well
what could you change that to i mean i
guess you just fill it up just a black
band
yeah
yeah a black heart
um yeah i don't know what they do i like
because you know
like what people black out a tattoo like
why don't they just use skin color
that's true just put flesh tones on it
well then you uh then if you ever got
any skin color yourself like from the
sun
it might be weird
um
you should just get what you should just
get the johnny depp tattoo just wino
forever
okay
so he's not the only one
um
uh who is speaking of johnny depp who
would you want to play you in a in your
biopic
oh it had to be a young person right
yeah yeah full head of hair
no one comes to mind i i don't yeah
i guess you could play yourself
you're so unique to me that you'd
probably have to play yourself
um what uh oh you know who could play
you was nicholas brawn
okay nicholas nicholas braun would be
good uh at playing you he's a good actor
all right i don't know
very good
what's your what's your uh i i'd be mad
i'd be mad that i wasn't cast in it
it'd be funny you know it'd be really
funny if you got an audition you had a
great audition for it
to play my dad
yeah
yeah what was your dad's name cecil
cecil great name wow
she's not
um
your favorite fruit dave what's your
go-to fruit apples
uh-huh a particular type uh granny smith
or uh no uh red delicious
oh yeah yeah for some reason they're
always the cheapest those red i love red
delicious
yeah cheaper um
uh who uh who's your favorite simpsons
character um is um um
homer
uh-huh yeah that's been uh
yeah we might have to change that
question up because it's been such a
common answer it's uh but he is it's
hard to beat homer because there's a lot
of love there i mean yeah yeah and we
used to ask uh your favorite muppet who
would if you had a favorite so long uh
who's who's the crazy one animal animal
yeah yeah yeah was that a common one uh
no but occasionally yeah there'd be an
animal i think uh it was fairly common
yeah um but it makes sense i mean he was
such a great he was so dynamic and
it was one of those guys that i feel
that way about you when i see you in
movies they're always you cut to them
and they're always doing something
fun or interesting or you know they're
they're like cut away wrong yes yes yes
offensive
and and uh
maniacal uh
dogs are cats do you prefer
dogs
yeah you have a dog
we do we have well we have three dogs at
my ex-wife's house okay um beetles or
the rolling stones stones
oh okay you have a favorite song
favorite era uh beast of burden
yeah if you play beast of burden i'll
listen to it a thousand times i love it
yeah i love it i love i love all stones
uh yeah i mean you've seen them
disrespect but you know after
uh emotional rescue things get a bit hey
take a longer break
that's terrible because i love the
rolling stones
yeah i don't know you know
just tour
yeah
it's true
you don't have to do undercover of the
night you don't have to that's true you
don't have to do steel wheels tour just
do the stones tour yeah i know i know
i'm sorry well hopefully one of them is
listening
um of course just with tear like at
their
like turks and caicos retreat yes and
they'll go you're the worst person in
anchorman okay well fine but
well whammy
i often think uh the same thing for
comedy you know at some point like okay
now you're just kind of an old man doing
comedy that's not funny
that's why it's important to do live
yeah does this still work
that's interesting am i only doing
something that's yeah
i've never thought about it that way but
um
yeah i mean like i never tired of seeing
for example don rickles that's exactly
who i was thinking of yeah yeah me too
that's my first thought was like except
for don rickles just keep doing yeah did
you ever meet him
he i got to once yeah i was like he
insulted me in ways that i can't repeat
which is like what you want you know
exactly yeah
i i just i was out with uh four of my
improv buddies we were all in our late
40s maybe early 50s
and i was that
whatever i was the most famous person at
our table yeah and he was having he and
his wife were having dinner with carol
burnett and her husband
and god carol burnett happened to be at
steve carell's unveiling of his star in
the walk of fame
oh so on things like how can i get over
there how can i get over there how can i
get over there and i was like hi how are
you uh i don't want to bother you uh
carol uh i don't remember i was at steve
carrell's uh dinner or lunch luncheon
for a walk of fame because you want to
say i have a legitimate yeah it's okay i
can be here
yeah
it's okay i can interrupt your dinner
all right i don't have my ticket on me
but they gave me a ticket to the party
i'm in show business
um
and then i think rickles gave me a
did you mean to wear that
[Music]
that's
shirt
do you remember what type of shirt it
was it was a western shirt
yeah yeah and you start laughing right
away right of course yeah oh we're all
just like oh oh yeah so but we didn't we
didn't dawdle too long we you know like
five of us and so we kind of but
everyone wants to kind of go i was on
this and he was on that and he was on
that you know it's okay
yeah you start doing your credits and
like just like i
yeah just just to make yourself um
give yourself some sort of status yeah
yes like it's okay i can i can talk to
you
i'm not well i guess i'm not like the
others
you know
because if a stranger comes up to you at
dinner yeah yeah you're like well thank
you so much and then then you'll go can
we get a picture if you catch me on the
way out if you're a dinner dave i'm
sorry i'm holding you up so long just
the last thing uh i i i wonder if you
can think if two words if you can give
me two adjectives that you would want
people to use when describing you once
you've you've you've gone once you've
left the earth what are two
words that you would like people to call
you just to
okay that it has to be um
funniest
and kind
yeah yeah well
i'll be saying if if it happens that you
go before me i will i will i will
definitely be saying those too
uh
i i i two truer words could not be said
about somebody i i love you so much
truly i love you too i i've loved you
since the first time i met you i love
you every time i happen upon you on
instagram i've always felt like i mean
we don't see each other much but i i
never feel apart from you no likewise
yeah yeah and forever that's how it'll
be i i
that's why anchorman was uh just such a
blessing uh forget that i wasn't in it
but um i got to it introduced me to you
so yeah i will forever be grateful for
that so thanks buddy thanks for doing
this
i love you i love you too okay see you
soon peace
[Music]
well
that just happened i'm trying to champ
whammy that is hard to do it's hard you
need to like
you just need to push it so hard that
you almost
keel over you know and he like that's
how much he
well that's why he spends that's why he
talks about how sweaty he gets when he
does that was gross he gives so much i'm
it was truly like sad you were like i
put on your headphones and like you were
about to dance around
and he goes they're wet
they were i always knew when he was
there i mean they would tell how could
they not be that i mean the way he
performs i know he's it would be weird
if they weren't wet he's just so dynamic
you know and we didn't really talk much
about this but he um
he was very kind to do uh a character he
calls gerald tibbens
uh he did it with a friend of his the
gerald gerald naked trucker act they
used to do it at largo if you're
familiar uh in los angeles they used to
do it it was such a fun show and you'd
see everybody there at the show it was
you know like chad apatow and all those
guys would go but it was um he played
this kind of like
uh hillbilly character did you almost
say something else redneck yeah that's
bad now it is bad but it doesn't seem
like it should be that bad because
redneck just me i don't know if
you're out in the sun a lot right but
it's but it's pejora it stands for it's
come to mean somebody uneducated yes so
it is i guess bad i thought he was
joking about that zoom roast company
that he started
for a while i thought it was like a long
weird bit well he
was just two bits like that where you
would just pop into someone's zoom thing
and like interrupt it and then i
realized oh this is a real thing and
then it's kind of good and i realized
that's kind of a good idea yeah yeah it
is it is i know it's funny it's i can
understand why you'd think that because
he does joke that way he's one of those
like
very he commits to everything yeah he's
a real committed oh yeah we just jump in
there zooms and
oh david packer to that character and oh
yeah cause i don't know the office as
well as you do
oh you don't no the british one i do we
were we've been well
there's an equivalent oh is it uh finch
yeah christmas oh oh he plays that
character oh god that's right okay so
and it's like by far the most despicable
character on the show oh interesting
yeah so he always plays those guys
that's funny well maybe is it because he
kind of he could look like one of those
guys he's big and he looks like a jock
like a big kind of bully he does jock
yeah it is interesting that he's so not
that guy just knowing him he's just it
makes him a good actor
yeah he doesn't get that credit i don't
think he doesn't get enough credit for
being a good actor you know this story
he told about doing that corporate roast
or like multiple corporate roasts where
he um
you know these like
multi-multi-millionaires
have these like vendetta roasts where
they like want to [ __ ] on one of their
friends that's crazy they don't have
they only have 50 million dollars
and it's
parties and he said that
some girlfriend of some very very like
well-known rich person
put
some molly the drug in his wife's mouth
do you remember him oh my god yes
oh my god it made me so curious
who that rich person was who that rich
person's girlfriend was because that's
such a despicable thing to do it is i i
mean this is unfair but elon musk is
jumping to mine only because i know he
is a filthy rich person not a filthy
comma rich person but um he also seems
to really like drugs
does he oh yeah he's i mean weed i don't
right but that's different than that's
true of course no i'm using it as a
maybe a gateway maybe you're right
but that you're right that's different
than like being into we he's just so
into weed elon musk the detail
to which he goes into the details
of his children being born
really took me by surprise it was a real
turn i was watching
i was watching you listen to it because
i i and i had kind of forgotten it
because we had recorded it a while ago
um
and i you you it's such a funny um
i have to remember this as an actor
because you had such a subtle reaction
but it was so
it was it was so big it was like such a
big subtle reaction you know you were
just like you like moved your head a
little bit like
you barely registered it physically but
it was there because you went so
smoothly
about like
uh his dad
you know manufacturing farm equipment
to
uh getting [ __ ] extracted out of his dick
that was funny and like placenta and all
come extract without missing a beast
it was the same tone you know what i
think may have really done it i mean may
have thrown you the most is his use of
the word come
that's a crazy word it's a gross word to
say casually
and i just did
and which is strange because it's also
such a casual it's when it's used
the way it's usually used together
come on people now smile on your brother
um but it's it's usually used in a very
inoffensive like very mundane way it's
very sad that um
david kechner's
is no longer married and he it's clearly
i mean it must be so difficult
especially after having the kid the
journey that he had with i know having
the kids imagine going through all that
oh my god i can't i can't and then and
when he talked about having the tattoo i
know with her name on it and i mean he
was able to be funny about it and make
light of it but i can't imagine how hard
that must be for him yeah it's um and
she kept the dogs too
yeah three dogs you're like do you have
dogs he's like you have three of them
but they live in my ex-wife's house oh
god yeah oh no three dogs five k five
kids and how about his son joining who
was like i mean obviously people can't
see him but he uh
he was huge and like good looking kid
lanky like 21 you know just but um he
really loves you and he when he was
talking at the end about how much he
loves you it's he sounded like champ
kind
of telling ron burgundy how much he
loves him yes he was like i just got to
say every time i see you i feel like a
special place in my heart okay there all
right i was just waiting for him to be
like we should
get a place together and move in
together i i love that scene that's
worth watching people listening uh wake
up i know we talked about it but wake up
ron berg it's really funny there's some
and stuff that uh i love that through
line where he's yeah i need love i know
he's like we i but i just love that
because there's always that guy in a
group of like when there's an alpha oh
my god guys and all the guys are like
yeah trying so hard looking at him the
leader yeah and like if you push that
idea
a little farther yes it becomes that
that's what's so funny about it it
becomes like i'm in i'm in love with you
i'm obsessed with you i'm in love with
you and i want to like settle down and
the irony is those guys are often i mean
in like a traditional sense those groups
of men are
there's often uh homophobic elements you
know when they're hanging out and stuff
and
it and it just it just like
illuminates how thin that line is
between
homophobia
and
homophilia
and and you know that it's uh often case
it's the ones who are professing more
homophobic stuff are the ones that are
that's what helps make it so funny it's
the best it's such a funny dynamic uh
let's read that letter okay
did i overexplain that
no i like when jokes are overexplained
okay
this is from rebecca adair
subject ugly cackling and
ugly cackling at zead joke oh man i
can't believe we left that joke in that
like because it's so specific to that
show 90 day fiance well rebecca adair
appreciated it yeah i dare you to find
somebody else who'd write a letter of
appreciation about that okay um
i wonder how they're doing okay rebecca
rebecca says thank [ __ ] i live alone
because i could not stop laughing at the
stupid zead joke i was already planning
on writing in when justin said he made a
utah jazz sign in shop i'd forget that i
say these things i was like how did she
know that but that joke sent me over the
edge curious as to why you touch ass
good question rebecca um
i know yeah what's your theory it's not
it's not just a theory i'm very very
confident okay tell me tell rebecca um
you liked the utah jazz when you were a
kid yeah because there was a player on
the team named john stockton who
was um the best point guard in the
league
and probably maybe in history uh yeah i
mean he's uh
he's in the top five
magic johnson
maybe jason kidd i mean there are other
players who rival him as a point guard
for sure
but he has the record for most assists
which is the key stat for a point guard
and at the time he was amazing and he
was also allen iverson
yeah also he was um
of caucasian descent yes and
then he was a little decent and he was a
little nerdy looking so i think
you as someone who vaguely resembled him
with very dark hair
and very light skin
you kind of floppy hair dark flower
floppy area you like identified with him
and you liked him in part because you it
was easier for you to picture yourself
in his position yep so you ended up
liking the team yes
is that accurate very accurate there's
also another element which is what i
thought the colors were cool for pulling
yellow i thought they had cool yeah they
did have cool uniforms yeah and carl
malone great the mailman oh man i loved
them all the um
that was his nickname yeah no i'm not
not like the mailman liked him too all
right man that just for clarity's sake
yeah hornystack jeff hornisek who turned
out to be a great coach let's get back
to the letter really charming daughter
okay um
curie says okay curious as to why you
taught jazz there you go uh that
four-minute explanation how to suffice
uh back to rebecca i'm a born and raised
utahn that's how they say it yeah utahn
utan u-t-a-h-n huh
yes i was raised mormon hell no i'm not
anymore and no my dad did not have
multiple wives now that that's out of
the way
i'm not a sports ball person
not even the jazz so i was wondering
what inspired justin to do that well
there you go yeah
i think we covered that sufficiently
i'm a surgical assistant for an oral
surgeon oral and after being on my feet
10 to 11 hours a day i thank david bowie
my higher power that i have y'all to
listen to on my way home
you make my day with every episode oh
thanks rebecca so nice
uh thanks for bringing so many smiles
laughs into the world
now for the finale i i didn't mean to
swallow that that's a really nice thing
thank you now for the finale would you
rather have
yes would you rather have ibs or a rash
that covered your entire body
great great question well sometimes i
think i have ibs um
uh
all right i've had both actually i have
it
it really depends on what the severity
like i would say if the rash
also came with an itch
i think i think that's implied a rat i
think rationalities come with ditches
okay well i would all of them
i would
rather have ibs i think
because i'm i think i'm vain enough
that having a rash all over my face yeah
that's true it would be difficult to go
through life you don't both have to be
that level vein that you would not want
to rash all over your face but you'd
rather have ibs yeah and ibs is
difficult i know some people with it and
uh i i wouldn't want to have it but who
do you know with it shout outs
uh but i think there are things i mean
like worst case scenario if you're
not near a bathroom you and you know
you're not going to be you just make
certain well precautions that take some
precautions that's the thing because ibs
in a way can be relieved easier than
a rash i would imagine well in this case
the rash doesn't happen and that's what
i'm saying in this hypothetical that's
what i meant that it can't be relieved i
would take the ibs
yeah
me too it's i guess it depends on where
you are in public yeah how severe it is
too yeah because if you're giving a
speech on it like a you just have a
diaper that would suck to have to work
you know i was just thinking about it it
would suck it would suck i mean both
would suck but i would um i would prefer
um that's a good question that we're
back at okay and then she's back to her
okay that was lame i don't think it was
lame um but i doubt you'll read this on
air so it doesn't matter well ha ha
fooled you
so you get for doubting thanks for all
you do
becca and thank you rebecca for writing
in this ah you mean becca yep there's a
funny letter and um is a good would you
rather you shouldn't doubt yourself and
i'm really glad to know that somebody
listening enjoyed my zead joke
that's really encouraging
and if you would like to write in our
email address is life is short at
wondery.com i wonder if the ed's
listening and thank you to the hilarious
kind-hearted oh yeah man
he's a fun guy to hug you get a hug from
because he's so big he leans out you
feel like a kid
uh i would like to hug him one day he's
great yeah he thinks we're twins and he
he said that um it's a stain on me that
uh he thought that and he's right he's
yeah i i also saw you listening to that
part you're like yeah yeah yeah that's
right yeah not a huge stain we're both
you know the older we get the more uh
less of a stain
the more appropriate it is that we would
look the same age by the way three years
doesn't isn't a whole lot when we're
when you're middle aged oh 9 52 i have
to get to my checkup okay well i have a
doctor's checkup which
i'm always i'll always be a little
nervous for it there's no reason also
now because you're reaching a certain
age there's a different reason to be
nervous about certain things they might
have to do to you certain exams yeah
that they um i know that's on the
horizon it is and i
and i know it's good to do by the way we
should we have a platform we should tell
men of a certain age that they should
start getting they're very important yes
checked katie couric would yes remind
you of that too yeah friend of the show
um katie would say yes get your
prosthesis checked um
[Applause]
and uh thanks for listening we'll talk
to you next week guy had fun doing this
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is ghosted by me
justin long it's go ghosted and produced
by you christian long as well as
produced by megan v
monaco senior producer is michelle
mieshlands
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers yes marshall louie
for the laundry have a nice week
everybody
[Music]
that's such a buzzkill
coffee ice cream but that uh
oh that orange creamsicle i mean coffee
ice cream's like the opposite of that to
me
it's like bitter
adult flavors actually
might be sweeter than we're giving it
credit for i'm sure it is actually you
know
in a sugar cone yeah
all right maybe soften it up a little
bit all right fine twist my arm i'll
have some coffee ice cream
all right if it's soft enough
i mean it is
you